we will now go through a very simple
example in which we just get to use the
formulas that we have available the
Poisson process is a pretty good model
of email arrivals at least during a
limited part of the day
for example during daytime emails may be
arriving as a Poisson process with a
certain rate but then during night time
they may be arriving as a Poisson
process with a different rate
nevertheless the assumption that we will
make is that at least for this problem
that emails arrive as a Poisson process
with a fixed rate of five messages per
hour what is the mean and the variance
of the number of emails received during
a day well we have formulas for the mean
and variance and in this problem we have
a lambda equal to five and tau consists
of 24 hours so the answer is 5 times 24
and this answer applies to both the mean
and the variance because for the Poisson
random variable these are the same what
is the probability that we get one new
message
in the next hour this has to do with the
PMF of the number of arrivals during the
next hour and that PMF is given by the
Poisson probabilities we are asking for
the probability of one new message so
that K is equal to 1 in the next hour so
that tau is equal to 1 so we're looking
for this expression here and using also
that lambda is equal to 5 we enter those
numbers in this formula and what we
obtain is 5 times e to the minus 5
finally what is the probability that
during each of the next 3 hours you
obtain 2 messages so this is an event
which is actually the intersection of
three events the event of two messages
in this hour two messages in this hour
and two messages in that hour for the
Poisson process we have assumed that
different time intervals are independent
of each other so what we need
to do is to multiply the probability of
two messages in this hour with a
probability of two messages in that hour
and the probability of two messages in
that hour on the other hand for each one
of the hours the probability is going to
be the same so it's enough to take the
probability of two messages during this
hour which is in our notation this
quantity and multiplied with itself
three times so we get the third power of
this now this expression is equal to the
following lambda times tau is five K is
equal to two so we get five squared then
we have an e to the minus five term and
K is equal to two so we're dividing by
two and we take the third power of this